la seule question que que j'ai envie de
vous poser finalement un Shimon Perez
c'est pourquoi ça n'a pas marché Oslo la
vraie raison
bonsoir Simone Perez bonsoir ancien
Premier ministre d'Israël organisateur
des accords d'Oslo prix Nobel de la Paix
boutros-ghalie bonsoir bonsoir ancien
ministre des Affaires étrangères
d'Egypte lors du voyage de Sadate à
Jérusalem ancien secrétaire général de
l'ONU André versaï fondateur et
directeur des éditions complexes vous
publiez Boutros-Ghali Shimon Peres 60
ans de conflits israélo-arabe témoignage
pour l'histoire ancien bouquin
passionnant parce que ce sont des
entretiens croisés entre deux acteurs
essentiels de l'histoire du monde deux
adversaires sur un ton beaucoup plus
politique que diplomatique absolument
c'est la première fois je crois qu'il y
a mes mêmes je crois au XXe siècle deux
personnes de ce niveau-là de cette
importance là qui décide de se
rencontrer alors que la guerre n'est pas
terminée même s'il y a une paire entre
l'Égypte et Israël c'est quand même fait
froide et le monde arabe n'est pas en
paix avec Israël aujourd'hui c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire et donc malgré
tout ils prennent le risque de parler
ensemble c'est à dire de tricoter
ensemble leur mémoire si on peut dire
ils ont tous les deux le même âge donc
ils ont vécu par définition les mêmes
choses au même âge mais chacun d'un côté
la frontière ce qui est important aussi
c'est que votre égalit est un Égyptien
ce n'est pas un Palestinien on revoit
trop souvent le ce conflit comme
uniquement il sera à l'eau palestinien
ce qu'il est devenu essentiellement à
l'heure actuelle mais quand on voit sur
60 ans sur 60 ans d'histoire c'est
beaucoup plus un conflit israélo-arabe
donc ça me semble important de les
mettre en laisser de les mettre ensemble
pour avoir un dialogue qui comme vous
dites n'est pas diplomatique mais
politique c'est-à-dire que ils se disent
vraiment les choses ce n'est pas fleurer
moucheté pas du tout c'est vraiment et
on a décidé de ne rien gommer de ne rien
gommer que il y a une opposition
frontale même si elle est respectueuse
bien sûr mais on a vraiment aussi les
deux mentalités la mentalité serait la
mentalité israélienne et la mentalité
arabe c'est très réussi en tous les cas
bravo je vous remercie à l'initiative
merci
alors ce qui est clair l'ensemble du
livre c'est vos éveil respectifs à la
politique Boutros vous avez 13 ans quand
en 1935 l'Italie de Mussolini envahit
l'Éthiopie du Négus et ça vous révolte
parce que vous y voyez la tutelle de
l'Europe sur le monde africain et le
monde arabe ce qu'on appellera par la
suite le tiers-monde oui j'ai à ce
moment d'acheter des timbres ont ramassé
de l'argent
j'avais des parents qui sont partis
comme volontaires des médecins donc j'ai
vécu cette et lorsque le Négus a passé
par le canal de Suez pour aller à la
Société des Nations j'ai pleuré pendant
toute une journée ça vous a marqué ça
beaucoup oui beaucoup et ça a été très
important par la suite oui c'est-à-dire
que à ce moment je ne savais pas
qu'est-ce que c'est que le colonialisme
je n'ai aucune idée mais je me sentais
plus près de l'Éthiopie que voilà alors
shiman vous vous êtes né en Pologne dans
une famille sioniste vous êtes allé en
Palestine vous aviez 11 ans c'était en
1934 et à l'époque dites-vous la terre
était traversée par une population en
domicile fixe il y avait pas de peuple
distincts il y avait les Arabes de la
région et pour Israël c'était une terre
sans peuple pour un peuple sans terre
c'est vrai
j'étais sûr que nous sommes seuls
et lever à quelques villages arabe mais
pas beaucoup
en principe c'était une tard un endroit
complètement juif qui parle complètement
hébray c'est assez en grande sensation
pour moi pour nous tous parce que nous
avons une revienne pas seulement vers
les termes mais aussi vers la langue et
la langue est peut-être plus importante
que le terme c'est les fondations de
culture
alors en 1945 à la fin de la guerre le
monde découvre le système nazi et le
génocide des juifs mais pour les Arabes
dites-vous Boutros Boutros-Ghali c'est
un problème entre européen et vous dites
en créant Israël finalement les
Occidentaux se mettent en règle avec
leur conscience mais ça n'est pas un
problème arabe c'est ça d'autant plus
que nous commençons à vivre une période
de décolonisation du départ des
étrangers et nous voyons de nouveaux
étrangers qui viennent s'installer en
terre arabe alors les Américains on
apprend ça dans le bouquin sont partagés
en fait sur le sort à réserver Israël il
y a le président Truman qui est qui est
pour mais Marshall celui du plan
Marshall est contre il y a une chose
comme qui est très intéressante c'est de
savoir pourquoi ce sont les Juifs qui
réussissent à emporter le morceau si je
peux me parler comme ça puisque les
Juifs sont quand même décimés au
lendemain de la guerre le monde arabe
représente une force quand même beaucoup
plus importante que le mouvement
sioniste qui a la guerre n'a pas
vraiment d'importance et c'est eux qui
vont réussir diplomatiquement à avoir
une influence sur Truman et il a une
urgence très très importante puisque si
ces Truman qui va véritablement faire
que la le plan de partage va se produire
donc il est intéressant de voir que et
c'est justement c'est l'analyse que fait
Boutros-Ghali il dit c'est vrai que les
que les Juifs sont décimés mais ceux qui
étaient aux États-Unis avaient toutes
les toutes les ficelles connaissaient
exactement avec tous les réseaux et
connaissait le Monde diplomatique alors
que le monde arabe était beaucoup plus
provincialisé et ne savait pas écouter
coloniser et économisée entièrement
colonisé n'était pas indépendant il y
avait des troubles d'occupation dans
tous les pays arabes oui mais ce que
vous dites aussi c'était colonisé par
les Ottomans par le Turcs
les peuples Palestiniens jamais
n'avaient pas le goût de
alors le 29 novembre 1947 l'ONU se
prononce pour la partition
55% de la Palestine est donnée aux Juifs
qui ne représentent que 37% de la
population et 45% au Palestine
évidemment le principe est refusé aussi
bien par des Palestiniens que Parlement
arabe et il faut aussi distinguer les
résolutions des Nations Unies étaient
pour une état is juif et pour un État
arabe pas palestinienne
cette pièce de terre n'était le sel il
avait beaucoup des autres pour le monde
juif c'était les selles pièces
historiquement et aussi si vous voulez
dans le foie
comme ça on ne peut pas comparer un
monde arabe c'est grand c'est large
et nous un petit peuple sur un très
petit pièce de terre quand les palestin
n'avaient jamais
ni l'un de pendances ni la terre ni la
reconnaissance aussi des mandats
en train de sous-estimer la lutte des
Palestiniens pendant
l'occupation anglaise pendant le mandat
de 1920 22 23 à 1945 à une opposition il
y a eu des massacres
comment vous avez eu des réunions qui se
sont tenues ok il y avait un mouvement
palestinien extrêmement important
de respect pour toi vraiment mais les
grandes mofté assey allait avec Hitler
il a collaboré oui jusqu'à
fait alliance avec tout le monde
oui mais c'est lui à mon avis si les
mouvements pas le Seigneur commencer le
négociations les Renaissance Juifs
Palestine commençait à la même temps sur
la même droite c'est pas de venir
vraiment en compréhension YouTube entre
nous deux en place on commençait le
lutte quand on n'avait pas ni l'État ni
le réseau ne nous étions déjà là alors
pour vous en tous les cas Boutros-Ghali
vous dites que les Européens créent un
état
occidental en terre arabe vous parlez
dans le livre et c'est là où j'étais
assez choqué quand même vous parlez de
fée colonial vous dites que c'est
comparable au royaume des Croisés sauf
que dans ce cas là il s'agit d'une d'une
association judéo-chrétienne ce
comparable à la présence française en
Algérie c'est comparable à la présence
anglaise au Kenya c'est la vision du
monde arabe il y avait pas des français
en Algérie il y a 2000 ans quand même
non mais d'accord mais si vous devez
rentrer de Milan il y avait il y a 2000
ans il y avait les Égyptiens et les
pharaons qui occupaient cette partie du
monde donc à ce moment je peux dire que
c'est un territoire égyptien les vrais
mpe
Palestine était le ottoman par les Juifs
après il avait lasagne anglais qui
remplacé l'empire de ottoman après les
autres nous nous étions pas ni en MPO
né en force elle monte juif était entre
en catastrophe
précédent quelque chose terrible et les
Anglais qui gouver par le CN à cette
époque là ne donnait pas la permission
aussi pour les réfugiés juifs arrivaient
à Nice comme ça on ne peut pas comparer
Israël avec un empire nous n'étionne pas
nous étions
peuple dans la catastrophe sans pareil
sans solution
et nous n'avons pas allé en Israël pour
contrôler le VI arabe pas de tout le
monde arabe est non alors il y a deux il
y a deux faits comme ça qui sont
étonnants dans votre bouche et d'abord
effectivement le fait colonial si vous
dites que c'est une colonie finalement
Israël une colonie occidentale au
Moyen-Orient et puis vous employez aussi
le terme de nettoyage ethnique parce que
au moment où Israël est né 700
000 Palestiniens sont partis de d'Israël
alors ce qu'on dit généralement c'est
pour faire place net on dit généralement
que c'est les gouvernements arabes
alentours qui ont dit partez parce qu'il
va y avoir une guerre vraiment dure
contre les Juifs donc allez vous en
comme ça vous ne souffrirez pas des
dommages de guerre c'est une des
théories l'autre théorie c'est ce que
vous dites c'est qu'en fait il y a eu un
véritable nettoyage ethnique opéré par
les Israéliens sur les Palestiniens qui
habitaient là oui je pense qu'il y a eu
actuellement il y a il y a des
historiens
rien qui le reconnaissent et qui disent
qu'il y a eu un nettoyage ce sont des
brouillés à faire partir ces
Palestiniens
j'étais là
je ne suis pas besoin de lire l'histoire
j'étais à côté de benguyons à cette
époque
pour garder tout le monde arabe en
Israël c'était les grandes moustiques
qui a dit les Arabes à pas le scénario
nous allons attaquer Israël nous allons
gagner la guerre il faut qu'il vous
quittez la terre et après nous
retournons avec les grandes victoires ce
n'était pas l'initiative israélienne de
tout et tous les livres
ne font pas au canapé sur moi-même j'ai
été là j'avais d'autres personnes qui
étaient là qui disent le contraire mon
cherchez peut-être relever
les choses que j'avais vu
alors on en arrive au point de vue
terrorisme palestinien pour vous Boutros
Boutros-Ghali évidemment il est pas
justifié mais il est expliqué pour vous
à partir du moment où c'est une colonie
il est normal qu'il y a une guerre de
décolonisation et les terroristes en
fait dans ce cas-là deviennent des
résistants et non plus des terroristes
des résistants au service de la cause
sacrée exactement comme vous avez eu des
T de terroristes de du côté israélien
et comme vous avez eu et ce que je
reproche chez mon prince vous avez
actuellement des assassinats ciblés
vous avez éliminé une une cinquantaine
de responsables palestiniens on les
assassinant alors que vous aurez pu les
juger
et vous allez me répondre c'est une
action préventive pour chaque pays qui
cherche indépendance il y a des
alternatives des bois de boire des
grandes
Mandela et devoir de terreur à mon avis
si le monde parle le Seigneur
suivant l'exemple de Nelson Mandela
Mandela on a déjà
et possède un état palesté un clair
parce que c'est contraire notre
tradition contre la vie des autres nous
voudrions pas
occuper ni la hauteur ni leur vie
par les terreurs de suicide qui est très
compliqué
les moyens ne sont pas simples les
problèmes c'est Israël jamais ne
commencez le terreur jamais c'est
toujours une réaction peut-être en
actionne provincible
c'est-à-dire que vous avez commencé
avant
en disant je m'attends à une attaque
donc je l'élimine d'abord la prenons un
exemple précis prenons un exemple précis
prenant
à partir d'un hélicoptère par exemple
vous vous considérez que c'est du
préventif c'est un shiman
non
certain
organisation terroriste clairement il
demandait tu es les femmes les hommes
femmes c'est très compliqué c'était pas
une raison pour le tuer
bon nous n'avons pas tiens il était
très longue temps dans notre prison avec
beaucoup de respect mais quand nous
avons quand nous avons trouvé qu'il
prépare notre
terre seulement contre je dis que
cette année il était paralysé il était
malade il avait une valeur symbolique il
était paralysé il avait
accepté les meilleurs traitements
médical à une Israël et la tête
avec les spéciales conditions les
conditions spéciales prison c'est une
prison mais il était complètement libre
si il arrêtait
son nez appelle
pour tuer le peuple vous avez dans
certains cas vous les arrêtez et vous
les jugez bon et dans d'autres cas vous
les condamnez à mort avant même de les
juger vous les assassiner comment vous
expliquer ça j'ai pas expliqué ça parce
que aucun attaque par notre armée
n'était pas fait sans le conseil
de notre juge
c'est c'est souvent le jugements
international
chaque condition est ionique différence
et chaque attaque est jugé
par le Home de
l'école comment vous allez quoi vous
allez un juge va condamner quelqu'un à
amor sans même l'écouter sans même
savoir que ce qu'il fait sans un
jugement
cette fois il se lève le matin il décide
de le tuer tu es apprenez en exemple je
peux prenez un autre exemple
si vous restez en information qui a
quelqu'un avec un bon dans les mains
qu'il va attaquer dans deux minutes
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire 7000 siège
était en assistant ce n'était quelques
hommes
noble supprime cette terre malgré son
titre
il encouragerait les autres pour tiers
les peuples qui sont complètement
innocents ce que vous encouragez
quelqu'un que vous êtes condamnéaire il
avait c'est pas l'encouragement c'est un
organisation avec beaucoup de pouvoir
les moyens
des jours jour après jour il faut
arrêter qu'est-ce que vous pouvez pas
vous avez kidnappé un certain nombre de
chefs Palestiniens vous n'allez pas pu
le kidnapper le condamner après son
prison
pourquoi pourquoi dans certains cas vous
les kidnapper puis vous les juger et
sont condamnés à 20 ans et dans d'autres
cas vous décidez froidement de les
associer
pour arrêter ces messieurs c'est
toujours préférable
mais si vous n'avez pas le temps et si
vous avez au point que le choix c'est
entre mourir
au sein de fendre il y a les règles pour
cela le choix reste vivant
il n'est pas le Cher n'est pas aucun
droit attaquer quelqu'un il n'est pas
aucune droit organisé à l'organisation
pour tuer les peuples pourquoi mais vous
n'avez
quelqu'un mais c'est pas quelqu'un c'est
pas quelqu'un cette admission
extrêmement dangereux qui est
responsable pour les mots personne
qui leur donnait le droit
attaquer les femmes en tant que les
enfants qu'elle cherche là
si nous parlons céramique spiritual
les premières choses respectaient les
vies de tout le monde
alors en 1964 l'ONU qui avait voté pour
la naissance d'Israël
assimile le sionisme au racisme alors ça
a été annulé depuis mais c'est très
intéressant de voir vos positions sur
cette décision de l'ONU pour vous Shimon
Peres on réduit l'expression nationale
des Juifs à une forme de racisme donc
vous trouvez ça extrêmement grave et
pour vous Boutros vous dites non les
Palestiniens étaient sur cette terre
depuis des siècles ils ont droit d'y
retourner ils peuvent faire tourner
alors que les Juifs du monde entier
bénéficient d'un droit de retour
automatique et vous dites c'est une
discrimination c'est un racisme
religieux et ethnique écoutez vous avez
un million de Palestiniens qui ont la
nationalité israélienne et qui tendent
des citoyens de ce grand ordre non vous
allez me dire non non
il y a le problème psychologique que
j'ai expliqué dans quelques mots d'abord
qui sont les jugés les juges qui
décidaient que c'est le racisme
c'est beaucoup de personnes dans la
science que elle-même était raciste
qu'elle même discriminelle est peuple
nous avons aussi un million de Juifs
dans le monde arabe on était forcés
quittait les places il ne faut pas
oublier cela comme ça c'est pas un cours
complètement objectivement et il faut
dire que historiquement assez de peuples
tu es beaucoup de juifs
et appelle les victimes le raciste c'est
un peu en exagération des histoires de
juive c'est plutôt
interne victime et par quelqu'un qui
discriminait les autres je n'ai pas pas
accepté avec tout le respect pour le
rassurer c'est cette cause historique
pas du tout
pas de tout il y a parmi eux qui a tué
1000 personnes dans beaucoup d'endroites
prenaient Saddam Hussein il peut être un
juge pour le racisme
alors voilà ces entretiens croisés sont
passionnants comme vous le voyez ils
couvre 60 ans d'histoire alors il y a le
voyage de Sadate à Jérusalem avec le
fameux discours à l'acné 7 vous aviez
écrit un discours boutros-gali mais
c'est pas celui-là qu'il a c'est pas
celui-là qu'il a dit oui ça a été ma
grande déception
il y a comme David la paix séparée en
Israël et l'Égypte donc vous avez été un
des évidemment des organisateurs il y a
l'assassinat de sa date cela a été
assassiné parce qu'il avait fait la paix
avec avec Israël je pense parce que
surtout ils étaient assassinés parce
qu'il avait l'opposition des
fondamentalistes les fonds de la
pantalys parmi les reproches qui lui
faisaient c'est d'avoir signé la paix
avec Israël alors il y a sabraï châtila
alors il y a une vraie nuance
terminologique là-dessus c'est à dire
que les Israéliens n'ont pas pratiqué
évidemment les massacres de de sabre à
Chatila qui ont été pratiqués par des
milices libanaises contiennent mais on
parle de passivité ou de complicité
d'aide voyons mais je l'ai aussi dans le
livre je vous ai donné des choses
précises
j'étais parmi les 1400 000 personnes qui
fait un démonstration contre moi
comment un résultat Sharon était
arrivé devant de notre
on donnait un jugement il faut être
précis avec leur jugement on a le dit
que c'est pas l'armée israélienne qui
participait dans le horrible
événement là
mais les responsabilités d'armée
israélienne
c'est qu'il n'avait pas faire le
prévention mais il n'y avait pas
participé là pour nous c'est un choc
mais à mon avis il ne peut pas comprise
sans comprendre
que les bases est toujours morale
il n'est pas être resté en juif sans en
appel moral il y a les autres à
considération
clairement il faut défendre votre vie
mais finalement et c'est pour cela que
nous avons démontré
contre Shakira parce que nous n'étions
partis
les lignes morales les limites
et finalement vous êtes assez d'accord
sur un truc c'est que leur émergence a
été favorisée par le fait qu'il serait
elle s'est construit sur des bases
religieuses peut-être
je veux dire que je pense que une des
raisons qui encouragé développement
du fondamentalisme je ne dis pas que
c'est la première c'est que c'est dit
bon si l'État d'Israël a réussi à avoir
une armée a réussi à défaire ou à gagner
tant de victoire contre tout le monde
arabe c'est une des raisons c'est que
c'est un état qui a pas qui est basé sur
une base religieuse donc nous aussi si
nous voulons réussir autant avoir une
base religieuse vous êtes d'accord avec
ça dans le livre
être pour la paix c'est sûr être pour
l'amour les mots religions
ne demandaient pas qui veut devenir un
organisation des terres je pense que les
majorités des Palestiniens chez nous
sont pour la paix sont pour en rapport
complètement différent
on dit toujours que c'est Israël juive
sont capables des hommes les raisons
pour tous ces problèmes
les Irakiens attaquaient les Hérens
c'est complètement
dehors
de guerre du monde arabe
c'est les fanatisme religieux pas le
religion elle est fanatisme religieuse
de notre époque on sent contre les
modernité quant à chaque personne qui
est moderne contre chaque événement qui
est moderne on veut garder les vieilles
vie sans changement et cette impossible
tel que est la même temps religieux
musulman un modèle on peut être moderne
pas être religieux il parle
contradiction alors là nous sommes
d'accord mais vous avez un
fondamentalisme juif aussi oui bien sûr
mais sans les armes avec les arguments
oui il y a une différence si vous êtes
extrême sans les armes cet angle mais si
vous tirez à cause des religions c'est
un autre chose on n'a pas besoin
d'utiliser les armes vous les avez
utilisé pour vous dans vos assassinat
ciblées dans vos représailles que vous
faites dans le téléchargement
alors vous parlez évidemment des accords
de slow et on se dit que aujourd'hui
quand on regarde la situation telle
qu'elle est au Moyen-Orient la seule
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
finalement un Shimon Perez c'est
pourquoi ça n'a pas marché Oslo la vraie
raison
d'abord le grandes surprises qui sait
comment c'est ouais c'était un entre
réduction complètement différent que
tous les autres
nous avons à cheval aboutir quelque
chose qui est complètement important
c'est la première fois qu'il est
Palestiniens étaient reconnus comme un
peuple on établir une personnalité
palestinienne avec en face nous avons un
problème sans loi
ne pouvait pas commencer avec lui nous
ne pouvons pas terminer
il changeait son avis dans les moteurs
des routes vous voyez l'avenir comment
Boutros je pense que dans le livre ceux
qui m'oppose chez mon père c'est que lui
c'était un optimiste et moi je suis un
pessimiste c'est peut-être dû à mon
caractère et c'est dû à son caractère
mais c'est ça qui est la différence
parce qu'après tout si vous voyez au
début du siècle les Palestiniens av au
centre du territoire puis ils ont passé
à 45%, puis maintenant ils sont à 22% et
je ne crois pas qu'ils auront 22% parce
que si vous ajoutez le mur que vous avez
construit ça va être ça va ça va être 10
minutes pour cent
donc écoutez indépendamment de ceci je
pense que malheureusement il faudra
attendre encore une génération avant de
pouvoir engager un véritable dialogue je
ne pense pas je pense que seront les
enfants de chez mon père est ce qui eux
pourront voir la paix mais lui je ne
pense pas qu'il la verra qu'elle a
essayé quelque chose à poutreuse nous
avons le même âge
les optimistes et les pessimistes en
fait disparaissent de la même façon mais
ils vivent différemment alors pourquoi
vous restez pessimiste devenons
optimiste et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu